It's still 360p!
It is!
But I did the output!
Oh no!
Ah!
Big Mac!
No!
What do I do?
360p stream and sing old songs.
Now I'm tired because I'm tired of this bullshit.
What the hell?
Does it sound okay at least?
People who watch the Vaughn are we going to be so confused?
I could say buddy up bandwidth.
It sounds okay.
You sound fine.
Let's do a test song Let's see how it sounds then.
Maybe.
What would be?
Oh.
I think I know a good song for this.
For this.
Hold on.
Let's see if I can find it.
Oh!
I found it.
Okay, I'm going to sing this song.
oh i forgot to turn on the okay i'm gonna make sure okay
let's this is a test to see if the audio gets all wacky too
it just jumped oh wait i don't want to sing this then
hi hi hi hi hi hi hi where's my samurai
I'm a search for a man All across Japan Just to find, to
find my samurai Someone who is strong But still a little shy
Yes, I need, I need my samurai Aye, aye I'm your little
butcher fly Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the
sky Aye, aye, aye I'm your little butcher
I've been searching through the woods up on the hills just
to find, to find my samurai.
Someone who won't regret to keep me in his net.
Yes, I need, I need my samurai.
Aye, aye, aye, I'm your little butterfly.
Green, black, and blue make the colors in the sky.
Aye, aye, aye, aye, aye, aye.
Hi, hi, hi, where's my samurai?
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, where's my samurai?
Oh, I don't know this part.
Butterfly.
Smile, DK.
Hi, hi, hi, I'm your little butterfly.
Green, black, and blue make the colors in the sky.
I'm your little butterfly, green, black, and blue, make the
colors in the sky.
Hi, hi, hi, I'm your little butterfly.
Green, black, and blue, make the colors in the sky.
Hi,
colors in the sky.
Hi, hi, hi,
hi, hi, hi, where's my samurai?
Song for 360p, but now I'm in 1080p.
The effect is ruined.
Hi, hi, hi, I'm your little butterfly.
Green, black, and blue Make the colors in the sky
Am I actually?
Oh gosh, okay, well, um, Welcome everybody!
I... It's awkward now Because the start of the stream is
weird now.
I'm watching in 360p.
Okay, good.
Oh, welcome, welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome.
I manually set you to 144p.
Eyes can't see more than 44p.
80p i don't believe that the start of all your streams are
weird shut up shut up uh yeah um i drank some coffee and i
was like whoa because i just did a meet and greet at a
convention and now i'm like well what do i do to get all
burn all this energy off why not do a crazy karaoke um so
i'm just gonna sing whatever i want and um burn the zoomie
energy yeah i'll do it until i'm tired and uh isn't it like
10 p.m it's like 11 p.m and i had coffee for the for the
meet and greet because i had to be i had to be energetic and
excited to see people of course so um yeah
i don't know what to do um what's another one what's another
song oh my gosh now i did butterfly that was butterfly from
smile dk that's from ddr ddr but now i'm like should i do
like i don't know i saw some people being like oh guess i
won't go to sleep now crazy frog okay i'll do all the I'll
do all the crazy songs and then we'll do Sending the Super
Wallet See?
Oh my gosh, Verlan, I hope you're having fun.
Wait, who does a crazy frog?
Wait, crazy frog?
Jingle bells.
CDR songs only.
Axel F?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I'll do all the crazy songs and then I'll do the slow songs
to wind us down, right?
Oh, how does this go?
Ding, ding.
This is the crazy frog!
Ding,
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Ding, ding.
Where
we...
This is the crazy frog!
I never knew...
Axel fandom I never knew that that this that this song had
wait I kind of want to hear what the person sounds like and
Kara Fung you can like hear what they what they what the
person like okay here let's see let's listen to the lead
person real quick
what's going on on somebody scream that was uh that was fun
that was good good suggestion everybody i feel crazy right
now it sounded perfect thank you somebody scream it's like
my favorite sample ever scatman Oh,
thanks for the 20 gifted.
I'm the Scatman.
There's actually words to this song.
Everybody's saying it's a scat man stutters, but he doesn't
ever stutter when he sings.
But when you don't know what I'm going to tell you now, that
the stutter and the scat is the same thing.
Yo, I'm the scat man.
Where's the scat man?
I'm the scat man.
Why should we be lazy and unapologize your teeth?
And who would change you if the season if they could?
The state of the condition insults my intuitions, and it
only makes me crazy in the heart like the wood.
Everybody stutters one way or the other, so check out my
message to you.
As a matter of fact, don't let nothing hold you back.
It's the scat man who can do it?
Oh, bro, say that, man.
Everybody stutters one way or the other, so check out my
message to you.
As a matter of fact, I don't let home the back of it, so
Scatman can do it, so can you.
I hear all I've got the meaning of scat...
Well, sleeping, the saints are weeping, because things are
called dead.
They haven't had the chance to be bored.
Ah, I'm the Scatman.
Where's the scat man?
That
was the scat man.
With the scat plan.
Maybe not.
Any openings from Full Metal Panic.
I appreciate you.
I think I only know one.
One Full Metal Panic song.
Mambo number four.
5!
Oh my god.
Why is multiple people requesting I can do it?
Mambo number 5.
I don't plan on doing... Here, let me write the full metal
panic for later.
I don't plan on only just doing Japanese songs or English
songs, so, you know.
This is certainly nailing the caffeine high vibe.
Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Mambo number 5!
Oh, ladies and gentlemen, this is Mumbo number five.
One, two, three, four, five.
Everybody in the car, so come on, let's ride to the liquor
store around the corner.
The boys say they want some gin and juice, but I really
don't want to be a buzz.
Like I had last week, I must stay deep because talk is
cheap.
I like Angela, Pamela, Sandra, and Rita.
And as I continue, you know you're getting sweeter.
What can I do?
I really beg you, my Lord, to me.
Just like a sport, anything flies are all good.
Let me jump in and send in the trumpet.
A little bit of Monica in my life, a little bit of Erica by
my side, a little bit of Rita's all I need, a little bit of
Tina's what I see, a little bit of Sandra in the sun, a
little bit of Mary all night long, a little bit of Jessica,
here I am, a little bit of you making me all mad.
Jump up and down and move it all around Shake your head to
the sound Put your hands on the ground Take one step left
and one step right One to the front and one to the side Clap
your hands once, clap your hands twice And if you look like
this, then you're doing it right A little bit of Monica in
my life A little bit of Erica by my side A little bit of
Rita's all I mean A little bit of Tina's what I see Sandra
in the sun, a little bit of Mary all night long, a little
bit of Jessica, here I am, a little bit of you makes me
you're mad.
A little bit of Monica in my life, a little bit of Erica by
my side, a little bit of Rita is all I need, a little bit of
Tina is what I see.
A little bit of Sandra in the sun, a little bit of Mary all
night long, Here I am.
A little bit of you makes me your man.
I do all to fall in love with a girl like you.
Cause you can't run and you can't hide.
You and me gonna touch the sky.
Cause
I'm haunting you guys, you know.
Mambo number five.
Ha!
The lyrics to that are a little...
That's like every VTuber, you know?
It's just like, I was scrolling, I didn't expect to come by
Yubito.
Hello!
Hello, hello!
She's still doing mean songs, throwing in my hat for...
Hey, hey, yay.
Like, hey!
Oh, Numa, Numa!
I don't know how to sing it though.
Okay.
What language is the song in?
Because, uh...
I feel...
like I'm gonna butcher it.
Romanian.
I'm so sorry.
I'll do the Disney version.
What?
There's a Disney version?
No way.
Wait, what's it called?
Hold on.
Also, what song did you mean, Nano?
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I said, hey.
Oh, it's going on.
Himan Sung, what is that song called?
Ma'hi, ma'a-yahoo, ma'a-ha Ma'a-ha'a Ma'a-Yahee, ma'a-hoo,
ma'a-ya-ha Ma'a-Yahee, ma'a-hoo Ma'a-ha-ha
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
Hello.
Hi Duke Citerol Girobrile May I promise you Where is it?
Hello Hello Pico, Pico, Pico Cipi Cipi, Cipi Cipi, Cipi,
Cipi, Cipi, Cipi, Cipi, Numa,
Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, numa, numma Numa, numma itch, Gi put
少 si draguls san tindie Me a mixteste o chidaire Vresa,
numa, numma, numma Numa, numma  Bella numma Numa, numa, 주,
sie, drago san tinde Me, mixtaste o a chi tairei Let's hear
these weird So, now, hello, hello,
hello, I'm Jesse, Picasso, I'm David, she's a floating, but
I don't know, there's no way, no way, no way, no way, no
way, no way, no way, no, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa,
Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa,
Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, Numa, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N,
N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N, N,
N Maya
Oh, I forgot to put the set list.
Sorry, that was...
Oh, Drago's...
I think I spelled that right.
The music video for that is crazy.
Oh my god, because saying Aqua.
Oh my god, what if they have erotic on here too?
That was amazing.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I think I've really butchered that.
Am I in the 2000s?
I'm sure Romanians are happy.
I'm sure Romanians are asleep.
what was the song what was the can you do tequila spanish
song brew hair brew hair yeah but one of songs iron mouse
sings oh my gosh i don't even know it though what's the what
is that one what's it called the parent trap song wait i
don't know that one neither.
They have a wonderful energy.
Thank you!
Oh, what's going on?
Is that what it called?
What's going on?
I actually don't... You know what?
I think I don't know what that song is.
Is this it?
I wonder.
Four non-blondes.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I don't think this is it.
Four Four blondes.
Wait, that's it?
Oh gosh, I don't know the song at all.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think.
Why is there four?
Oh.
Wait, let me try this one.
Four non-blondes.
Why are they not blind?
Yeah, this is more like it.
This is more like it.
Yeah, yeah.
Years ago, my left...
trying to get out that big hill of hope for destination am i
singing it right who cares i quick realized quickly when i
knew i should that the world was made up of this brotherhood
a man or whatever that means i don't know and so i cry
sometimes when i'm lying in bed just to get all out my head
and I'm feeling a little peculiar.
It's got a weird phasing it does.
And so I wake in the morning and I step outside and I take a
deep breath and I get real high and I scream, oh I scream
for the top of my lungs.
What's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I said, hey, what's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I said hey what's going on
oh and
I try oh my god do I try I try all the time in this
institution and I pray oh my god do I pray I pray every
single day for a revolution And so I cry sometimes when I'm
lying in bed Just to get it all what's in my head And I'm
feeling a little peculiar And so I wake in the morning and I
step outside And I take a deep breath and I get real high I
scream from the top of my lungs, what's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I say, hey.
What's going on?
And I say hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, yeah.
I say, hey, what's going on?
And I say, hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, hey.
I say, hey.
What's going on?
And I say, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, I
said, hey, what's going on?
25 years and my life is still trying to get off that great
big hill of hope.
donation
gosh joy tom tom thank you for the double 50 gifted thank
you did i see that right oh my gosh you're the greatest ever
do it fast car by tracy chapman what's that one fast car i
don't know if i know it let me hear it duvet by duvet uh let
me add it duvet There's such a beautiful voice.
Oh.
I think I know this one.
We need some cascading on two.
Mahjong twos.
Wait.
Do I know this one?
You've got a fast car.
I want a ticket to anywhere.
Maybe we can make a deal.
Maybe.
Oh my God.
Look at this.
I don't know if I know it well enough, though.
I don't know.
Zero got nothing to lose.
Maybe we'll be able to make it so that me my...
I don't know what well I'm up, I'm sorry.
I think I know maybe the...
Fast car.
I don't know what the...
Maybe I know of the course.
You've got a fast car.
I've got a plan to get us out of here.
You've been working at a convenience store.
I don't know.
I'm so sorry.
I know this song, but I don't know the pacing well enough.
I tried.
I tried!
Okay, back to 2000 there is.
And I'll do Boa next.
I still hear your voice when you sleep next to me.
I still feel your touch in my dreams.
my weakness but I don't know why.
Without you it's hard to survive.
Cause every time we touch I get this feeling and every time
we kiss I swear I could fly.
Can't you feel my heart be fast?
I want this to last.
Need you by my side.
Cause every time we touch I feel the static and every time
we kiss I rest.
reach for the sky.
Can't you hear my heartbeat so I can't let you go?
Won't you in my life?
Oh gosh, I'm eating.
Your arms are my castle, your heart is my sky.
May wipe awake tears
The good and the bad times We've been through them all You
make me rise when I fall Cause every time we touch I get
this feeling And every time we kiss I swear I could fly Can
you hear my heart beam fast?
I want this to last Need you by my side Cause every time we
touch I feel the static Every time we kiss, I reach for the
sky Can't you hear my heartbeat so I can't let you go?
Want you in my life?
I was like half chewing my food while I was singing that.
Every time we kiss, I swear I could fly Can't you hear my...
Oh, feel my heartbeat fast.
I want this to last.
Meet you by my side.
Yeah.
that was every time we touch oh my gosh i wonder if there's
any erotic on here no there's not how sad anything anything
by drama rama anything anything mama mia or the entire host
even that mama mia hold on let me do captain jack oh yo i
want to I wonder if that's on here.
Hold on, I'll write it down.
Captain Jack, what was that?
Anything, anything.
Okay, let me check, let me check Captain Jack.
I will do, I will do Boa, don't worry.
I will.
Hey yo, Captain Jack, hey yo, Captain Jack.
What was the song?
There was one song in DDR by Captain Jack I used to do all
the time.
I wonder if, what's this one?
Oh, thank you for it.
Thank you, Chaley Axe.
Hey, yo, Captain Jack.
Bring me back to the railroad track.
Ooh!
Run into the railroad track.
Run along with Captain Jack.
I don't remember the song at all.
Oh, shit.
But, yes, dream a dream.
Oh, my gosh, how'd you know?
Oh, my God.
That's the song I used to do all the time.
I don't know.
Left, right, right, left.
.
Run along with Captain Jack.
I don't know this song at all.
I wonder if they have dream a dream.
Dream a dream.
.
The military step The military step The Air Force rap The
Air Force rap The 17 is the best Oh shit, go left Go right,
go left, go left, go left Go left, go right, go left Come
here, we are running to the railroad
Left, what is this on?
Company, attention Forward
I wanna be a drunken man I wanna be a drunken man Left,
left, right, left The military step The military step The
Air Force rap The 17 is the best The 17 is the best The
left, left go right, go pick up the step Go left, go right,
go left Into
the railroad track Run along with Captain Jack
D-D-D-D-D-D-D-O Run along with Captain Jack Run along with
Captain Jack D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-O
Let's ride right, right left
Hey, Captain Jack Bring me back to the railroad track Give
me a woman in my hand Give me a woman in
my hand The military staff The military staff The Air Force
wrap The Air Force wrap The 17 is the best The 17 is the
best Forward March Run into the railroad track, run along
with Captain Jack D-D-D-The-D-Jack Run into the P-Stamp bag,
run along with Captain Jack D-D-A-D-O
Right, right, left Ba-D-D-D-O
I never knew that it cost in that song I never even knew I
like the other one Dream a dream Ba-Babada-Darada-Dah
Da-Dada-Dada-Dada Da-Dada-Dada
What was it?
Anything, anything, anything.
Men Phantom Reel.
See, someone was watching the panel today.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I don't know if they have it.
What's the Mama Mia song they have?
Mama Mia.
Cotton Eye Joe.
What is this?
What is all the...
theme all of a sudden.
Please Cotton Eye Joe.
Okay, Cotton Eye Joe.
Why?
This is the worst karaoke ever.
And then I'll do good songs later.
Well, these are good songs.
Wait, who does Cotton Eye?
Red Necks?
No way.
No way that's the name of the group.
Red Necks.
With an X.
If I am being for Cotton Eye Joe, I've been married a long
time ago.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
If I hadn't been to be for Cotton Eye Joe, I've been married
a long time ago.
Where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Where did you come from Cotton Eye Joe?
If I hadn't been for Cotton Eye Joe.
There's more to this song.
Oh, I've been married a long time ago.
This is the only part of the song I know.
Where did you come from?
Cotton Eye Joe.
If I haven't been for Cotton Eye Joe,
I am where did you come from?
Where did you go?
Where did you come from?
Cotton Eye Joe.
I always have Cotton Eye Joe.
Maybe I should focus on myself.
Maybe I have a bad personality.
Hey, hey,
hey, hey, hey, hey.
Even though I've been for cat night, yo, I've been married a
lot.
For
the raid!
Bobby girl.
This one's for you, Emily.
Thanks for the gift that you guys, thank you.
Wait.
Here we go.
Hi, Barbie.
Hi, Ken.
You wanna go for a ride?
Sure, Ken.
Jump in.
I'm a Barbie girl in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
Come on, Barbie, let's go party.
I'm a Barbie girl in a Barbie world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
I'm a blonde, bimbo girl in a fantasy world.
Dress me up, make it tight, I'm your dolly.
You're my doll, rock and roll, feel the glamour and thing.
Gives me here, touch me there, hanky, hanky.
You can touch, you can play.
If you say, I'm always yours Ooh, I'm a Barbie girl In a
Barbie world Life in plastic, it's fantastic You can brush
my hair, undress me everywhere Imagination, life is your
creation Come on Barbie, let's go party Ah, ah, yeah Come on
Barbie, let's go party Ooh, ooh Come on Barbie, let's go
party I am.
Come on, Barbie, let's go party.
Ooh, ooh.
Make me walk, make me talk, do whatever you please.
I can act like a star, I can beg on my knees.
Come jump in, bimbo friend.
Let us do it again.
Hit the down, fall around.
Let's go party.
You can touch, you can play.
If you say it's yours, you can touch, you can play.
If you say, I'm always yours Come on, Barbie, let's go party
Ah, ah, ah, yeah Come on, Barbie, let's go party Ooh, ooh
Come on, Barbie, let's go party Ah, ah, ah, yeah Come on,
Barbie, let's go party Ooh, ooh, ooh
It's fantastic You can brush my hair Undress me everywhere
Imagination, life is your creation Barbie girl, in a Barbie
world.
Life in plastic, it's fantastic.
You can brush my hair, undress me everywhere.
Imagination, life is your creation.
Come on Barbie, let's go party.
Ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
Come on Barbie, let's go party.
Ah, ah, yeah.
Ooh, ooh.
So much fun, Ken.
Well, Barbie, we're just getting started.
Oh, I love you, Ken.
Sorry to any Ken's in the chat.
That song makes me want to act.
That song makes me want to be Barbie.
Yay.
Superstar.
She's my wife.
Wait, did it have that?
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Love Fool by the cardigans.
Love you're singing too.
Love Fool.
Let me look it up.
Also, whoever requested anything, anything earlier, I
couldn't find it.
I'm sorry.
She's my wife.
Ah, she is my wife.
That's an acapella version.
No boa duvet.
I'm saving some of the slower songs for like...
later.
Right now it's kind of like all the funky fun songs and then
we'll do like the slower like so if you have a slower song
that's what I have it written down.
I'm gonna dancing queen!
Yeah let me look up love fool real quick see if I know it or
not.
Love fool.
Oh no I don't even say it on here.
Oh wait.
Hmm.
Let me see if I can find a karaoke on YouTube.
I don't even know if she is my wife would have a karaoke.
If you search up Dazuhira on your art tag, there's a
microphone for your first anniversary.
Oh, really?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I'll use it.
I'll use it next time.
Let me write it down though.
Dazu.
Thanks, Dazu.
I like how you're like.
If you search up Dazuhira, as if I don't know your name, I
know you Hercules Sundere song Okay You know me I'll always
do I'll always do I'll always do some nice Some Disney 7192
Thank you so much for the raid Thank you thank you Thank you
so much Thank you thank you Hope you had a fun stream
Streams by Fleetwood Mac Don't stop me now oh my gosh i
can't sing that song elizabeth sang that song way too well
she sang that song like she was the queen i can't stop
listening to her singing that it's so good it's so good oh
my gosh she oh i can listen i love how she had like her
karaoke like it was going on for like 10 hours today it was
crazy like all her unarchived stuff i was it earlier um what
was i searching oh love fool by cardigans karaoke let me see
hold on let me see if i know this first
oh i fear we're facing the problem you love me no longer i
know and maybe there is no thing that I can do to make you
do.
Oh, I can't.
Mama tells me I shouldn't bother that I ought just stick to
another.
Men, a men, let's share a men, serves me.
But I think you do.
I don't know this song very well.
So I cry and I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me, fool me, fool me Go on and fool me,
love me, love me Pretend that you love me, leave me, leave
me Just say that you need me So, oh, so I cry And I beg for
you to love me, love me Say that you love me, leave me,
leave me Say that you need me I can't care about anything
but you I have desperately pondered Spent my nights awake
And I wonder what I could have done In another way To make
you stay Reason will not lead to solutions I will end up
lost in confusion.
I don't care.
Oh my gosh, I've been forgetting to update the set list for
so long.
I'm so sorry.
Go.
So I cry and I pray and I beg.
Love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
Pretend that you love me.
me, leave me, leave me, just say that you need me.
So I cry and I am, and I beg for you too.
Love me, love me, say that you love me, leave me, leave me,
just say that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
I know that you need me.
I love me, love me.
Say that you love me.
Fool me, fool me.
Go on and fool me.
Love me, love me.
I know that you need me.
I can't care about anything but you.
Sorry, Oymo.
I think I butchered your song.
Okay, I will remember to update the set list now.
Or not set list, but the now playing.
I think on a vertical format, having a set list is hard.
Oh, sorry, my bad.
Go to bed when you need to.
Asian Kung Fu Generation Rewrite.
Ah!
I love that song.
I'm parasocial.
Dreams, dreams from nights.
I don't know that one.
I believe in a thing called love by the darkness.
Wait, do I know that one?
Oh my gosh.
You guys suggest so many songs.
I'm sorry if I can't get to everything.
Tattoo!
Okay.
I think I can sing Tattoo.
They're not gonna get us.
Wait, I don't know if I remember the song.
I'll try it.
Get us.
They're not gonna get us.
They're not gonna get us Not gonna get us Starting from here
Let's make a promise You and me Let's just be honest We're
gonna run Nothing can stop us Even the night That falls all
around us Soon there will be Laughter and voices Beyond the
clouds Over the mountains I don't know if I'm getting the
keys right at all.
Oh, that are empty.
Lights from the airfield shining above you.
Nothing can stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
They're not gonna stop us.
No, no, I love you.
They're not gonna get us.
Not
gonna get us Not gonna get us Uh oh, I think I'm getting the
rights wrong Not gonna haunt us We
rush ahead The crossroads are empty Our spirits rise They're
not gonna get us Always forever Just you and me All else is
nothing Not going back Going back there, they don't
understand They don't understand us
Not gonna get us
Nothing can stop us No, no, I love you They're not gonna get
us, they're not gonna get us Nothing can stop us, no, no, I
love you They're not gonna get us, they're not gonna get us
They're not gonna get us They're not gonna get us Not gonna
get us They're not gonna get us Not gonna get us
Wow.
I haven't heard that song in probably like 10 years.
That's crazy.
I tried my...
I don't know if I got the keys or like the verses read at
all.
Why does the background vocal sound like SpongeBob singing?
Someone suggested this earlier.
I'll do my best with it.
But don't compare me to a certain...
Um...
You know, singer.
I'm not a singer.
I'll take lessons.
I'll take lessons someday.
Tonight, I'm gonna hat myself a real good time.
I feel alive.
And the world I'll turn it inside out.
Yeah.
I'm floating around in ecstasy So don't stop me now Don't
stop me Cause I'm having a good time Having a good time I'm
shooting a star, leaping through the sky Like a tiger Define
the laws of gravity I'm racing car, passing by Like lady,
good time I'm gonna go, go, go Stopping me.
I'm burning through the sky.
200 degrees, that's why I call me Mr. Fahrenheit.
I'm traveling at the speed of light.
I want to make a supersonic mad out of you!
Don't stop me now.
I'm having such a good time.
I'm having a ball.
Don't stop me now.
If you don't want to have a good time...
Wait, wait, if you don't want to...
Don't stop me now.
Cause I'm having a good time Don't stop, yes I'm having a
good time Don't wanna stop at all I'm a rocket ship, I'm
women moors On a collision course, I'm a satellite I'm out
of control, I'm a sex machine Ready to reload, like in a
tomb bomb About to, oh, oh, oh, oh I'll explode, I'm burning
through the sky I
want to make a super sonic woman out of you.
Oh, why did I even attempt this song?
Don't stop me.
No, stop me.
Stop the song.
Don't stop me.
Good time.
I don't even know how to stop.
No stopping.
The sky, yeah.
200 degrees.
That's why they call me Mr. Fahrenheit.
I'm traveling at the speed of light.
I want to make a Suf Democratic Man out of you Don't stop me
now.
I'm having such a good time.
I'm having a ball Don't stop me now.
Wanna have a good time?
Just get me a call.
Don't stop me now Doesn't have a good time.
Don't stop me.
Yes.
I'm having a good
That's the rest?
Wait, I thought it went through the rest.
Oh my god.
Sorry, I've totally butchered that.
It's fine.
The coffee is starting to weigh down, actually.
That's why I'm, like, trying to eat, because I was like, oh
gosh.
The caffeine is, like, passing through me, and now I need
food, because I'm starting to shake.
Oh, good, good.
Mama Mia, time!
Okay.
You're a pretty good singer.
I'm not, but thank you.
I'm not.
Thanks, I appreciate it.
Mama Mia.
What's a song from Mama Mia?
Oh my gosh, go!
Thank you for the 50 gift and I think I- oh sorry.
I think I saw Paco right in me.
I think it was you Paco.
Thank you!
If you're still here.
Hello, I'm in Phantom.
Anybody who doesn't know.
Let's do Abba.
Abba Abba.
It'll be in my heart?
Oh my god, Nan.
It's like the one Disney song.
I don't know.
Holy moly that scared me.
You can dance, you can jive, have you
Who will see that girl?
Watch that scene, dig in the dancing queen.
Friday night and the lights are low, for a place to go Where
they play the right music Getting in swing You've gotta look
for a king Anybody could be that guy The night is young and
the music's high With a bit of rock music Everything is fine
You're in the mood for a dance And when you get the chance,
you are the dancing queen, young and sweet, forever 19.
Dancing queen, feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah, you can dance, you can shout.
And
oh, oh, we'll see that girl Watch that scene, take in the
dancing queen Watch
that stream You're a teaser, you turn him on Leave him
burning and then you're gone
Do, you're in the mood for a dance And when you get the
chance, You are the dancing queen, young and sweet old,
forever 19.
Dancing queen, feel the beat from the tambourine.
Oh yeah, you can dance, you can shine.
Oh, see that girl.
Watch that scene, digging the freaky queen.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
That was the dancing queen.
Young and sweet.
Hopefully that suffice for Mama Mia.
Because I don't know, actually, I only know.
Mama Mia, here I go again.
A bunch of us are at Anime Fest learning Otage to this
stream.
This Kenjo teaching you guys.
Nice.
Thanks for watching, even at Anime Fist.
Take on me!
Sometimes I only recommend songs that I know, and it's hard
to tell which songs you're familiar and not familiar.
No, it's okay!
Always feel free, like you can suggest a song just because I
don't know it doesn't mean I won't be able to sing it in the
future.
Song Bohemian Rhapsody?
I haven't.
I'll do it after this one.
Take on me.
Gosh, I need to warm up my voice.
I mean, I have been singing, but it's like...
I never do vocal warm-ups.
I just kind of was like, I'm just going to go in for this,
baby.
We're talking away.
I don't know what I'm to say or say it.
anyway today's another day to find you shying away i'll be
coming for you love okay take on me take me oh so
needless to say i'm at odds and ends but i'll be stumbling
away slowly learning that Life is okay, stay after me.
It's either too low or too high.
It's no better to be safe than sorry.
Take on me.
How do I do this by?
Take me on.
Take on me.
Call me God in a day or two.
My warm-ups for
me.
I was practicing the higher horn.
I don't even know the notes.
This is Piquan approaching.
All the things that you say.
Is it life or just to play my worries away?
You're all the things I've got to remember.
You shine away.
I'll be coming for you anyway.
Take on me.
Take me, oh no,
I'll be gone in a day or
take me on.
I'll be gone in a day.
Where's the two?
Take on me.
Take me on.
That part confused the hell out of me.
Oh, that was take on me.
My God.
You guys, why do I even sing?
Why do I even sing?
you guys even listening to me.
Got another suggest, Scatman.
Oh my gosh, wait, man, I did Scatman earlier.
I did, I did, I did, I did Scatman.
I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it, I did it.
Okay, I'm gonna do a song, maybe that actually, okay, hold
on.
Okay, serious time.
This song goes through my entire rage.
Ken just freaking out.
What's the song you can go at the gate, too?
Heavens divide.
Live in La Vida, loca?
Okay.
How do you know that song?
My God, Ricky Martin.
I used to have such a crush on that guy.
So do my grandma.
I think I...
Oh, it's a trick.
That's right.
She's into superstitions.
Black cats and blue dogs.
I feel a premonition that girl's gonna make me fall
She's into some sensations, new kicks in the candlelight
She's got a new addiction for every day and night She'll
make you take your clothes off and go dancing in the rain
She'll make you live her crazy life Take away your pain,
like a bullet to your brain.
Come on, upside inside, out.
Live in La Vida Loca, she'll pours and pull you down.
Live in La Vida Loca, her lips are devil-red and skin is the
color of mocha.
She'll sheer will wear you out.
Live in La Vida Loca, live in La Vida Loca, she's I've been
loving Aloka.
Woke up in New York City.
In a funky cheap hotel.
She took my heart, she took my money.
She must have slipped me a sleeping pill.
She never drinks the water, makes you order French
champagne.
Once you've had a taste of her, you'll never be the same.
Yes, she'll make you go insane.
Upside inside out, she's living La Vida Loca.
She'll push and pull you down, living La Vida Loca.
Her lips are devil-red and her skin is the color of mocha.
She will wear you out, living La Vida Loca.
Living La Vida Loca.
She's living La Vida Loca.
She'll
make you take your clothes off and go dancing in the rain.
She'll make you live her crazy life, but she'll take away
your pain.
Like a bullet to your brain.
Come on!
Upside, inside, out, mida loca.
She'll push and pull you down.
Live in the mida loca.
Her lips are devil red and her skin's the color of moca.
She will wear you out, living La Vida Loca.
Upside inside out, she's living La Vida Loca.
She'll push and pull you down, living La Vida Loca.
Her lips are damn all red and her skin's the color of mocha.
She will wear you out, living La Vida Loca.
She's living La Vida Loca What's that cause I got?
What is this part?
Come on Come on What is this part?
Live, live, live Vida Loca Gotta gotta I never knew what the
lyrics of that song were Oh my god He literally was just
like She made me up Or she made She drugged me in the night
And she took my money She's She gave me a sleeping pill, and
she took my money.
I'll never financially recover.
Oh my god, oh my god.
I'm kind of into it.
You're freaking.
Shadow Cross, thank you for the tiny gift, then.
Po-Poe-Poe.
You're upstream.
Tiny Princess, thank you.
Bro got scammed.
Living lovey to Loka.
Okay, it might be time to start, start, uh, start chilling
out.
Starting to get late in the night.
Bohemian Rhapsody.
I can do Bohemian Rhapsody.
What is the edit?
Hold on.
What's that?
Is that the holding out for, wait, holding out for a hero?
I don't know that.
Wait.
that one but i don't know that one is this the real life is
this just fantasy caught in a landslide no escape from
reality open your eyes look up to the skies and see i'm just
a poor coast I need no sympathy cuz I'm easy come easy go
little high little low anyway the wind blows doesn't really
matter to me to me mama just He's killed a man, put a gun
against his head, pulled my trigger, now he's dead.
Mama, life had just begun, but now I've gone and thrown it
all away.
Mama, ooh.
Didn't mean to make you cry If I'm not back again this time
tomorrow Carry on, carry on As if nothing really matters
Too late, my time has come Sent shivers down my spine Body's
aching all the time Goodbye, everybody I've got to go Gotta
leave you all behind And face the truth Mama
I don't wanna die I sometimes wish I'd never been born at
all.
Oh,
seven.
I see a little silhouetto of a man.
Scaramouche, scaramouche, will you do the Fandango?
Thunderbolts of lightning, very, very frightening me.
Galileo, oh Galileo, Galileo, Galileo, Figueroa, Magnifico,
But just a poor ghost, nobody loves me.
He's just a poor boy from a poor family.
Spare him his life from this monstrosity.
Easy come, easy go.
Will you let me go?
Bismillah.
No, we will not let you go.
Let him go.
Bismillah.
We will not let you go.
Let him go.
Bismillah.
We will not let you go.
Never let you go.
Never let me go.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, mama mia, mama mia, mama mia, let me
go Me is upon as a devil put aside for me, for me, for me,
yeah So you think you can stone me and spit in my eye So you
think you can love me and leave me to die Oh, baby, can't do
this to me, baby, just gotta get out, just gotta get right
out of here.
Nothing really matters, anyone can see.
Nothing really matters.
nothing really matters to me
except metal gear
anyway the wind blows
bohemian rhapsody maybe that was a good one to end in the
craziness right i don't know i might go back to crazy can we
get mama mia i don't know mama mia i'm sorry that's why i
sang dancing queen that's why i sang it live la vida oh yeah
it's a good one i might have to turn it up though let me up
the pitch elton john i'll put let me do elton john
actually i wonder if i can just sing this one
I used to rule the world Seas would rise when I gave the
word Now in the morning I sleep alone Sleep the streets I
used to Used to own Oh, I don't know I don't think so I
think it's too high I think it's too high Hold on, let me
start over I'm gonna do this Let me try one more time Let me
try one more time
I Oh The world Seize would rise when I gave the word Now I
sleep and I wait and leap alone Sweep the streets I used to
own Okay, I'm gonna do it one more time Okay, I know I know
it now Okay Are you guys sick of this opening?
Yeah, okay, there we go.
I used to roll the world.
Seas would rise when I gave the word.
Now in the morning, I sleep alone.
Sweep the streets I used to roam.
Again!
I used to roll the dice, feel the fear in my enemy's eyes,
listen as the crowd would sing.
Now the old king is dead, long live the king.
One minute I held the key, next the walls were closed on me,
and I discovered that my castles stand upon pillars of salt,
pillars of sand I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing Roman
cavalry choirs of singing Be my mirror, my sword, my shield,
my missionaries in a foreign field For some reason I can't
explain Once you go, there was never, never an honest word
That was when I ruled the world.
What's the meme lyrics?
It was the wicked and wild wind blew the doors to let me in,
shattered windows and the sound of drums.
People could not believe what I'd become.
Revolutionaries wait for my head on a silver plate just a
puppet on a lonely string oh who would ever want to be king
I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing Roman cavalry choirs are
singing be my mirror my sword my shield my missionaries in
the foreign field for some reason I can't explain I know st.
Peter won't call my Never an honest word, but that was when
I ruled the world.
Saint Mito.
Video of the king reminiscing this destroyed Minecraft.
I hear Jerusalem bells are ringing, Roman cavalry choirs are
singing.
Be my mirror, my sword, my shield.
Missionaries in a foreign field.
For some reason I can't explain I know St. Peter won't call
my name Never an honest word But that was when I ruled the
world What's the lyrics?
What's the Minecraft lyrics?
Minecraft
Chunks would load when I gave the word Hide the mobs I used
to slay Note block choirs.
It was the creepers and the skeletons blew down the doors
and boxed us in.
What is this?
This is so stupid.
I gaze off at the boundless skyline.
Note block choirs playing in the sunshine.
This is awful.
Oh my god, it's art.
Do one verse.
Okay, okay, I'll do it.
I'll do it.
Hold on.
Minecraft.
Wait, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, no, no, it's gonna
sound really funky for a second.
Wait.
Oh wait, I lost the lyrics!
Where'd they go?
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, hold on, hold on!
I exited out of the lyrics, I'm an idiot.
Wait, oh!
Oh,
okay, hold on.
Okay, I love BGM while I search for stuff.
I used to roll the world, chunks would load when I gave the
word.
Now every night I go stow away, hide from the mobs I used to
slay.
Yeah, I was so stupid.
They once were terrified.
Every time I looked into their eyes, villagers would cheer
my way.
For a hero I was, that's what they'd say.
One minute we had it all.
Next our world began to fall.
Away from it that I once become They all cried for my help,
but I stood there numb I gaze off into the boundless skyline
No flock choirs playing in the sunshine Turn around, pick up
my sword and wield The blade that once veered evil,
bomb-stealed And hope one day that this chaos and
destruction turns For the better, never above in hand that
was when I ruled the land it
was the creepers and skeletons blew down doors and boxed us
in arrows whizzing by like streaks of light I tried all that
I could to stay and fight as the undead roamed the street
families Life itself was suspended by a thread.
Oh, why was it that I wasn't dead?
I gaze off into the bound, the skyline No block wires
playing in the sunshine.
Turn around, pick up my sword and wield The blade that once
forced evil mobs to yield.
If this battle shouldn't leave me slain, I know Hero Pride
will call my name Take a stand That was when I ruled the
land Hi, Hero Bright Mansion Oh, oh, oh, oh
Chased off into the boundless skyline No flocked wires
playing in the sunshine Turn around, pick up my sword and
wield The plague that once forced evil to heal if this
battle should leave me slain I know here O'Brien will call
my name better to take a stand that was when I ruled the
land my crooked glasses just just bring it all together now
doesn't it oh there we go
good job everybody oh okay i'm starting to get tired i'm
starting to get tired i'm starting to get tired let's see
why i was kidding oh no okay
oops now i still have a little bit in me don't worry
and you don't seem to wonder A shame you seemed an honest
man And all the fears you hold so dear Will turn to whisper
in your ear And you know what they say, I hurt you And you
know that I mean so much And you don't even feel a thing I
am falling, I am fading, I have lost it all And you don't
seem the lying kind A shame that I can read your mind And
all the things I read, that I read there Candle-lit smile
that we both share I don't mean to hurt you But you know
that it means so much And you don't even feel a thing I am
falling I am fading I am drowning Help me to breathe I am
hurting I have lost it all I am losing Help me to breathe
Present day, present time, ha ha ha ha ha.
Help me to breathe, I am hurting, I have lost it all, I am
losing.
Help me to breathe, oh,
yeah.
Help me to breathe.
I am hurting.
I have lost it all.
I am losing.
Help me to breathe.
Yay.
Oh, I spelled it wrong.
I'm so sorry.
I spelled it wrong.
My bad.
Here, I'll make these a little bit bigger in case you can't
read it.
Yay!
Someone earlier requested Full Metal Panic.
Oh gosh.
You can probably find a karaoke if it's somewhere.
This is gonna be a real test to see if this gets blocked.
It's always the Japanese songs that get blocked.
Maybe I should have done a Japanese song karaoke in this
style, but you know.
Um...
Uh...
L-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l-l.
Hold on.
I'm looking it up.
Oh, I remember I remember.
I remember, I remember.
Oh, karaoke.
Let me check if this is good.
This song, I have to use a YouTube one.
It's from, it's uploaded 16 years ago.
You know what?
Who cares if the quality is bad?
This was supposed to be a bad quality stream anyway, right?
You're not here to hear me sing well.
lyrics
um uh uh uh
If it's a rain-a-gall-y-no-match If the wind is clear, now
I'm going to walk out.
If something starts to start, something starts to start.
If you're here, if there's no more, if there's no more, you
can't live here.
If you're not alone, I'm very close to you.
That's love, right?
I know how many times the pain and the pain you know, I know
what it means, but I'm going to see through the eyes in the
eyes and I'm going to look for the I want to see a lot more.
No, I don't know if there are
any other ways you can do it.
I'm just going to change the color of the colors.
Look,
there's one more thing.
I know that you know each and every one of you, now I'm
going to be able to hold you together I know that you're
together, it's going to be together.
That's why it's so good.
I don't know if you're going to see me.
I'm going to be there for you.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You're with me and your hand and your hand with your hands
and you're going to walk through the world.
The moment the moment the moment is not just a feeling but a
little little bit
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm not gonna lie, I started to
disassociate during the song.
am i i felt like an out of body experience i was like am i
is am i singing this right now um actually it's so funny
because i know that song is from full metal panic but i i um
actually know that song so well i've only i only watched a
few episodes of full metal panic because um when i was a kid
i owned some of the dvds right thank you for the 20 gift
thank you thank you for the time he gives a dick you um and
uh um but actually i know it the song so well because there
was a petite princess yushie amv to it that was made so well
and i fell so much in love with the song that i like always
watch the music the amv and also also listen to the song
does anybody remember print petite princess yushie anyway
i'm idea.
I don't actually remember the songs from that.
I don't remember.
Actually, there was an AMV.
I watched that too.
That was goodbye to you.
Goodbye to everything.
Oh my gosh.
Let's see.
Someone earlier requested Hercules.
There was something else I just saw.
And I was like, oh, this would be good.
i don't remember sorry somewhere over the rainbow you know
what oh i remember
i wonder this is a this is sorry this is a this is a a loud
song and then i'll go back to the sat or to the quiet songs
so i so so so no no
creep by radio head oh i don't i might be able to oh i don't
know can i sing that song can i try that one next time i
actually don't remember it at all i do remember it but i
wanna I want to do it justice.
I really like that song.
Okay, this one is like from my childhood.
I used to listen to this song all the time.
All the time.
I don't even think I'll be able to sing it very well.
But I just kind of want to sing it.
I just kind of want to sing it.
Broken this fragile thing now And I can't, I can't pick up
the pieces And I've thrown my words all around But I can't,
I can't give you a reason I feel so broken up And I give up
Just want to tell you so you know Here I go Scream my lungs
out and try to get to you You are my only one I let go But
there's no one who gets me like you do You are my only, my
only one Oh my gosh, I used to scream this as a kid Made my
mistakes, let you down And I can't, I can't hold on for too
long Ran my whole life in the ground And I can't, I can't
get up when you're gone Something's breaking up I feel like
giving up I won't walk out until you know Here I go Scream
my lungs out and try to get to you You are my only one I let
go There's just no one who gets me like you do You are my
only, my only one
Here I go Oh, oh, scared my life
My only one I let go No one, no one like
one I clearly don't remember the song well enough My only
one
My only,
only one
I could have sworn there was a there was a quiet part it's a
song I can't
am I crazy am I crazy I could have sworn there was a part
where he's like here I go maybe they cut the solo out really
that's what messed me up so much anyway that was yellow card
only one okay let's sing some Disney.
Disney.
What Disney song should I sing?
Disney, Disney.
Oh my gosh, it's easy.
Thank you for the fit to get to thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
When she loved me, I didn't I say, oh, I sang that in a
membership one, I think.
Oh yeah, it's, it's, okay.
It's quiet.
hours, everybody.
Quiet hours.
It's late.
It's time for quiet songs.
Wait, is this the right one?
No.
I think it's this one.
Sorry, my bad.
My bad.
We got some dramatic piano for no reason.
Everything was beautiful Every hour spent together Lives
within my heart And when she was sad I was there to dry her
tears And when she was happy So was I When she loved me
Through the summer and the fall, we had each other, that was
all.
Just she and I together, like it was meant to be.
And when she was lonely, I was there to comfort her, and I
knew that she loved me.
me so
the years went by I stayed the same but she began to drift
away I was left alone still I waited for the day when she'd
say I will always love
Lonely and forgotten Never thought she'd look my way And she
smiled at me and held me Just like she used to do Like she
loved me When she loved me When somebody loved me Everything
was beautiful.
Every hour we spent together lives within my heart when she
loved me.
Oh, sorry, I forgot to change it.
Yay.
I have another one I want to say.
I hope it's okay.
I haven't sung this one in a really long time, so I hope I
remember how to sing it.
Good.
Also, Jamie, thank you.
Look at me.
I'm as helpless as a kitten up a tree.
And I feel like I'm clinging to a cloud I can't understand I
get misty Just holding your hand My
way And a thousand violins Begin to play Might be the sound
of your hello.
That music I hear, I get minty the moment you're near.
Can't you see that you're leading me on?
want you to do.
Don't you notice how hopelessly I'm lost?
That's why I'm following you on
my own.
Would I wander through this wonderland alone?
Never knowing my right foot from my left, my hand from my
glove.
I'm too minty and too much in love.
Too misty.
and tune
in love.
Yay.
That was Misty.
But you could say Minty.
Yay.
Thanks for the claps.
Clap, clap, clap, clap, clap.
Clap, clap, clap, clap.
Thank you.
Skyfall, oh gosh.
I don't know if I could sing it tonight.
Micmac, thanks to the Five Gifted.
Making that borderline?
Maybe another night.
Fine, fine line from Avenue Q.
Have I ever sung this on stream before?
Hey, I'm Dragon.
Thanks for the Ten Gifted.
I used to audition with this song.
I used to audition for musicals.
with this song.
Good evening, Mito.
Good evening.
There's a fine, fine line between a lover and a friend.
There's a fine, fine line between reality and pretend.
And you never know till you reach the top the uphill climb
but there's a fine fine line between love and a waste of
time no I never got in there's a fine fine line between a
fairy tale and the lie and there's a fine fine line between
your wonderful and goodbye I guess if someone doesn't love
you back, it isn't such a crime but there's a fine fine line
between love and a waste of your time and I don't have the
time to waste on you anymore I don't think that you even
know what you're looking for For my own sanity I've got to
close the door and walk away Oh, there's a fine, fine line
Between together and not And there's a fine, fine line
Between what you wanted You gotta go after the things you
want While you're still in your prime There's a line by line
Between love And a waste of time
I was about to say something really mean
Oh man Yeah I never Maybe I should have changed what song I
auditioned with Because I never got into anything using that
song So Oh well I just really liked it though Say it
Oh no I don't worry She hates us No no Not about you It's...
It's about where I used to work.
Oh man.
Let's see.
I don't think I did any Disney.
Did I...
Let's see.
Someone... Oh, Hercules.
That's right.
What's that song?
Just a
box.
If there's a prize for a rotten judgment, I guess I already
won that.
No man is worth the aggravation.
That's ancient history.
Been there, done that.
Who'd you think you're kidding?
He's the earth and heaven, too.
You try to keep it hidden.
Honey, we can see.
Oh, no.
Girl, you can't conceal it.
We know how you feel, like, who you think.
Yeah, no.
Oh, no chance, no way, I won't say no, no.
You spoon, you stop, why deny it?
Oh, it's too cliche, I won't say I won't in love.
Sorry.
I thought my heart had learned its lesson.
It feels so good when you start out.
My head is screaming, get a grip, girl.
Unless you're dying to cry your heart out Oh, oh, you're
good, you're weird you are And how you feel, and baby, we're
not quiet Uh, we saw you hit theck I'm sorry, my throat is
so bad today Oh, no chance, no way I won't say it, no, no I
blame crazy fraud The grin you're in love I won't say I'm in
love
Your way, oh god, I won't say yet Get out of my case, I
won't say yet Need more water At
least out loud I won't say I'm in love
Like hearing your throat sounds.
What the hell?
I might unarchive this since there sounds so bad tonight.
Sorry.
I thought I'd be fine.
I'm so out of water, though.
It's okay.
I'm having fun.
What's another Disney song I like?
Hmm.
Golden hour?
Sound great, can it, nerd?
Takes one and no one!
Jeez.
Beauty and the Beast.
Wait.
Which version do I want to sing?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, no.
Not this one.
Wait, do I have to turn this?
this one up?
Do I have to, I don't remember if I have to up this one or
not.
I'll see you in a second.
Sally's song!
Oh, I can try.
It goes really high though.
Hold on.
This is a test.
I have to see if I need to pitch it up or not.
I was the one who had it all.
I was the master of my fate.
I never needed anybody in my life.
I learned the truth too late.
I'll never shake away the pain.
I closed my eyes, but she's still there.
I let her steal into my melancholy heart.
can bear.
Now I know she'll never leave me, even as she runs away.
She will still torment me, call me, hurt me, move me, come
what may.
Wasting in my lonely tower, an open door.
I'll fool myself, she'll walk right in, and be with me
forevermore.
I rage against the trials of love.
I curse the fading of the light.
Though she's already flown so far beyond my reach, out of
sight now I know she'll never leave me even as she fades
from view she will still inspire me be a part of everything
I do wasting in my lonely tower waiting by an open door I'll
fool myself, she'll walk right in And as the long, long
nights begin I'll think of all that might have been Waiting
here forever More
Oh, I couldn't hold it
Wee The song makes me cry every time.
Oh, oh, I forgot.
Oh, I guess it's playing a playlist.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I can sing this.
I can sing this one.
Oh, my gosh.
Almost there.
Yes, I made the choice.
For Papa, I will stay.
But I don't deserve to lose my freedom in this way.
you monster if you think that what you've done is right well
then you're a fool think again I always wanted to beat Belle
on Broadway so is my dream role my dreamest dreamest role is
this whole Is this where I should learn to be happy?
Never dreamed that a home could be dark and cold.
I was told every day in my childhood, even when we grow old.
My heart is never one word so true.
My heart's far, far away, home is due.
Is this home?
Is this what I must learn to believe in?
Try to find something good in this tragic place.
just in case I should stay here forever held in this empty
space oh that but that won't be easy I know the reason why
my heart's far far away homes alive what a I've geared to
return to the life that I knew lately, but I know that I
can't solve my problems going back.
Is this home?
Am I here for a day or forever?
Shut away.
From the world until who knows when As my life has been
altered once it can change again Build higher walls around
me Change every lock and key Nothing lasts, nothing holds
all of me My heart's far, far away, home.
It's only from the musical, Beauty and the Beast.
Oh, sorry, you can't read it.
Beauty and the Beast.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Someone requested, almost there.
Hold on, I know gold.
People have been screaming about Golden Hour.
Okay, I'll get it, I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll do it, I'll
do it.
Newsies?
I'm sorry, I actually don't know newsies.
It was just two lovers, sitting in the car, listening to
blonde, falling for each other.
Pink and orange skies, feeling super child.
There's no Donald Glover, Miss Glover, my mother.
Like we were yet tonight, got no alibi.
I was all alone with the love of my life.
She's got glitter for skin, my radiant beam in the night.
I don't need no light to see you shine It's your golden hour
You slow down time In your golden hour
We were just two lovers Feet up on the dash, driving over
fast, burning through the summer, radio on blast, make the
moment last, she got solar power, minutes feel like hours,
she knew she was the baddest, can you even imagine, falling
like I did for the love of my life, she's got glow on her
face, a glorious look in her eyes, my angel of light, I was
all alone with the love, of my life she's got glitter for
skin my radiant beam in the night I do see you shine it's
your golden
oh you slow down time
Oh The longest outro ever Out of caffeine?
I think so
Mama I don't have time to dancing that's just gonna have to
wait a while ain't got time for messing around and it's not
my style this whole town can slow you down people taking the
easy way but I know exactly where I'm going getting closer
and closer every day and I'm almost there I'm almost there.
People down here think I'm crazy, but I don't care.
Trials and tribulations, I've had my share.
There ain't nothing gonna stop me now, because I'm almost
there.
I remember Daddy told me, can come true you gotta make them
happen it all depends on you so I work real hard each and
every day now things for sure I'll go my way just doing what
I do look at boys I'm coming through and I'm almost there
I'm almost there people gonna I come here from everywhere
and I'm almost there.
I'm almost
there.
There's been trials and tribulations.
You know I've had my share.
But I've climbed the mountain, I've crossed the river and
I'm almost there.
Almost there.
You're there?
I don't think so, but that's okay.
I wonder if this song is on here.
Hmm, I don't see it.
Hmm, oh well.
Shadow Cross, six of the five gifted.
I never know.
Boy, just stop.
I always, always just want to keep going.
I'm trying to think, oh, someone requested this.
And I do kind of want to sing it.
It'll help us go to sleep.
Actually, it's a song that my mom used to sing to me to
sleep every night.
So I might cry.
I might cry.
It's probably not a song you hear very much in VTuber
karaoke, but that's okay.
Let's all go to sleep now, everybody.
Let's all go to sleep.
Let's all sleep now.
Somewhere over the rainbow, up high.
There's a land that I've heard of once in a lullaby.
Somewhere over the rainbow, the skies are blue.
And the dreams that you dare to dream really do come true
someday I'll wish upon a star and wake up where the clouds
are far behind me where troubles melt like lemon drops away
above the chimney tops that's where you'll find me
Somewhere over the rainbow Blue birds fly Birds fly over the
rainbow Why?
Can't I?
I don't know this version at all.
It says it's the Judy Garland version, but...
Happy little bluebirds fly Beyond the rainbow Why, oh why?
Yay, oh I'm not gonna lie, I was tearing up I was tearing up
Oh Oh Ha-hung shu, haung shu Any other lullaby songs?
What's another lullaby song?
What's another really quiet, soft song?
What's a song to sleep to?
It's a sad song when you think about it.
When you think about her, Judy Garland, I know, right?
Gosh, so sad.
Where's her whole thing?
Letter.
Break stuff, yeah.
Have a good sleep, Minto.
Thank you.
I'll do one more.
Moon River.
Oh my gosh, I did that song in a recital once.
What's that mean?
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
That's so sad.
Okay.
You know what?
End on a on a on a Metal Gear song.
Technically.
Actually, is there a slow version?
Is it only the fast version?
I think there's only the fast version, Let me see.
I think it's only the fast version.
Oh!
Oh, it's the slow version.
Okay, good.
Oh my god, it's buzzing in my right ear.
Wait, I think it picks up, actually.
Oh, 7, oh, 7.
I think it's gonna get loud in a second.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours, but agony is your
triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours, that agony is your
triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart, rest forever here in our
hearts.
The last and final moment is yours, that agony is your
triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart, Rest forever here in our
hearts The last and final moment is yours But agony is your
triumph Here's to you, Nicola and Bart Rest forever here in
our hearts The last and final moment is yours that agony is
your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
I'm sorry.
The last and final moment is yours, that agony is your
triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Oh, oh that's it.
Sorry I wasn't looking.
Oh, is I wonder if there's a I wonder if there's a slow
version Like MGS4 version Hold on, I'm checking Sorry Sorry,
I'm checking Hold on, let me see if this works It'll
actually be A real A real bedtime song then maybe
The slow version is from 4 Yeah, this one, the faster one is
I think it's the original one is the fastest one But it's
also it's also um it's also what's the word oh my gosh it's
also the one end of four is I think what I was gonna say
yeah yeah yeah yeah um hmm hmm sorry I'm checking I want to
make sure I get the ad libs right but you know what it's
it's fine I guess
Okay.
That should be it.
MGS4 version is so emotional.
It is.
I might not get the timing right when it starts, but...
Oh, I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling it.
It's so sad.
I
think it's now.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Bart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Nicola Embark, rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours, that agony is your
triumph.
Here's to you, here's to you.
Oh, here's to you.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you.
Oh.
heart.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, here's to you.
The final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Here's to you, Nicola and Ward.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony
hears to you, Nicola.
Rest forever here in our hearts.
The last and final moment is yours.
That agony is your triumph.
Good night, everybody.
Thanks for watching.
and um
this is good isn't it thanks for listening to my karaoke i
hope you guys have a good rest a good night i'll see you
guys tomorrow for metal gear if i see you if i don't see you
then you know i'll see you when i see you I'm always
haunting you, so all you have to do is believe, Simba.
Thank you for a crazy night.
Otsumi, though.